So, now we'll look
at third kind of sum
that comes up all the
time called harmonic sums.
And we'll begin by
examining an example where
they come up really directly.
So, here's the puzzle.
Suppose that I'm trying to stack
a bunch of books on a table.
Assume all the books are
the same size and weight
and uniform, and I'd like
to stack them up one on top
of the other in some way.
And try to get them as far
out past the end of the table
as I can manage.
Now, notice in this picture,
it seems kind of paradoxical.
The top book, the back
end of the top book
is past the edge of the table.
Is it possible to do that?
Is it possible to get the top
book, the back of the top book
past the edge of the table?
And how far out can you get the
further most book to the right?
That's the question
we want to ask.
Well, let's go back and
do it for the simplest
case, which is one book.
So, this amount will be a
function of how many books
we have.
We're interested in the
overhang using n books.
Overhang is the amount
past the edge of the table
that the rightmost end
of any book can be.
What do you do with one book?
Well, with one book,
assuming that the thing is
uniform, the center
of mass in the middle.
Let's assume the
book is of length 1.
So, the center of
mass of the book
is at halfway down the book.
And if that center of mass
is not over the table,
then you're going to have torque
and the book is going to fall.
So, you've got to keep the
center of mass supported.
And the way to get
the largest overhang
is to have the center of mass
right at the edge of the table
here.
And in that case,
you can get the book
to stick out half a book
length without falling.
And what that tells us is that
the one book overhang is 1/2.
It'll balance with
the furthest end
out exactly if the center
of mass is on the edge,
and I get a half a book
length for unit overhang.
Let's proceed recursively
or inductively.
Suppose I have n books.
How am I going to
get them to balance?
Well, let's assume
that I figured out
how to get a so-called stable
stack of n books, which
if I completely supported
it flat on the table,
it wouldn't fall over.
And I'm going to
show you how to go
from n to n plus 1, which
is how you construct
an arbitrarily large stack of
books that won't fall over.
Well, if the stack completely
resting on the table
won't fall over,
that means that if I
have the center of mass of it
past the edge of the table,
by definition of
the center of mass,
there's going to be an
equal amount of weight
on both sides of
the center of mass,
and the thing is going to
fall off the edge of the table
by the same reasoning
as we did for one book.
So, the stable and n
stack-- stable in the sense
that it won't fall over of
self if it was lying completely
over the table.
In fact, it won't fall over
as long as its center of mass
is over the table.
And to get it out
the furthest amount
to the right, what
I'm going to do
is put it at the
edge of the table.
So, now I know how to place
a stable stack of n books
to get the largest
overhang out of it.
What next?
Well, let's consider
n plus 1 books.
And what do I have to do?
So, I'm trying to
do the same deal.
Suppose that I have a
nice stack of n books
and I know how to support
it so it won't tip over.
And I now have n plus 1 books
and I want to get out further.
What do I have to do?
Well, by the basic reasoning
that we just went through,
now the center of mass of the
whole stack of n plus 1 books
has to be over the
edge of the table.
That's the way I'm going
to get out furthest.
So, I know where the center
of mass of n plus books
is going to be, at
the edge of the table.
What about the center of
mass of the top n books?
Well, I need them
to be supported.
I need their center of
mass to be supported.
They'll be supported,
providing their center of mass
is over the bottom
book somewhere.
And the way to get
it out furthest
is to have it over the right
edge of the bottom book.
So, I'm going to put
the center of mass
of the top n books at the edge
of the n plus first book here.
And that means that the
incremental overhang that I
get, the increase
in overhang that I
get by adding one more book,
we can call the delta overhang.
And it's the distance between
the center of mass of n
plus 1 books and the
center of mass of n books.
N here, and n plus 1 here.
Well, let's see what's going on.
The center of mass of the n
books is at some location here.
And the center of mass
of the bottom book
is halfway away,
half a book length
away from where the
n books are balanced
on the edge of the bottom book.
So, the center of mass
of the n books is here.
The center of mass of
the bottom book is there.
The distance
between them is 1/2.
And I need the table to be at
the balance point between the n
books and the one book.
That's where the center of mass
of the n plus 1 books will be.
So, I need to calculate
amount that's going to be,
the increase in overhang.
So, let's abstract
it a little bit.
The delta overhang
is the distance
from the n book to the n
plus 1 book centers of mass.
And if we think of this
as a balancing diagram,
there's the n books.
Or at least, there's the
center of mass of the n books.
There's the center of mass of
the 1 book, their distance 1/2
apart, which we said.
And they have to balance
at the edge of the table.
So, think of the edge of
the table as the pivot point
and it's there.
And I need to calculate,
where is that pivot point?
How do I get this fulcrum
or this balance beam
to balance with weight n
here and weight 1 there,
when their total
length apart is 1/2.
What's this distance?
That distance is the delta
that I'm trying to calculate.
Well, you just know from
physics that the balance point
is going to be the
distance 1/2 divided
by the sum of n and n plus 1.
I need the n times this amount
to equal 1 times that amount.
And if you check that out, it
means that delta is 1/2 over n
plus 1.
Or simplifying, 1
over twice n plus 1.
You should stare at that
diagram a little bit
and remember your
elementary physics
to realize the reasoning
behind the formula for delta.
Well, now I'm done
because basically, I've
just figured out
that the increase is
this delta overhang.
And now I know what it is.
It's 1 over twice n plus 1.
And so, what I can conclude
is that the overhang
of n books, B1 is
1/2 and Bn plus 1
is Bn plus 1 over
twice n plus 1.
So this is a recursive
definition of Bn,
but it's easy to
see how it unwinds.
It means that Bn is 1/2 plus
1/2 of 1 plus 1 plus 1/2 of 2
plus 1 plus 1/2 of
3 plus 1 and so on.
If I factor out the 1/2,
Bn is 1/2 times 1 plus 1/2
plus 1/3 out through 1 over n.
That sum is the harmonic sum.
The sum 1 plus 1/2
up through 1 over n
is called Hn, or
the harmonic sum.
And what we figured out, or
really the harmonic number,
is the value of that sum.
And what we figured
out is that Bn,
the amount that I
can get n books out
up past the edge of
the table is Hn over 2.